OK, so let's begin today's program with a story about a 25-year-old reporter, namely me at 25. This clip that I'm about to play you was on an NPR program called Let's Hear It, though I have to say, I think the 25-year-old me would find this intro that I'm doing right now to the story to be kind of mumbly and understated. Here's how 25-year-old me kicked off his story.
好的，让我们从一个关于25岁记者的故事开始今天的节目，也就是25岁时的我。接下来要播出的这段录音来自NPR的一档节目，名叫《听听看》，尽管我不得不说，我想25岁的我如果听到我现在这段开场白，会觉得它有点口齿不清，而且过于平淡。以下是25岁时的我如何开启他的故事。
And now, true-to-life adventure stories.
现在，让我们进入真实的生活冒险故事。
Yeah, I had flair. That's how I talked back then on the radio.
是啊，我当时很有风格。这就是我那时在电台里说话的方式。
Today's adventure story began this way. I was sitting outside the office of Betty Bird. She's one of the producers of this radio program, and she's blind.
今天冒险故事的开头是这样的。我正坐在贝蒂·伯德的办公室外。她是这个广播节目的制片人之一，而且她是盲人。
OK, I'm just going to stop the tape right there. I have so much to say about this, but I'm just going to let this play for a minute or two first. Stay with me here. OK, I'm outside Betty Bird's office.
好了，我就在这里暂停录音。关于这一点，我有太多话想说，但我打算先让这段录音播放一两分钟。留下来听听。好的，我当时就在贝蒂·伯德的办公室外。
And I overheard her tell this story. She was walking down the street. She was with a friend. And some woman, a complete stranger, walks up to the two of them, catches up to the two of them. And this stranger says to Betty--
我无意中听到她讲了这样一个故事。她当时正走在街上，和一位朋友在一起。这时，有个完全陌生的女人走到她们身边，追上了她们。这个陌生人对贝蒂说——
Well, how did you lose your sight? And I said, I don't usually share that with anybody except friends. And she said, well, I just want to know. I just want to know. When did you lose your sight, and how did it happen? And I said, well, I don't really care to discuss that with strangers.
“你是怎么失明的？”我说：“除了朋友，我不常和别人分享这些。”她说：“我就是想知道。我就是想知道。你是什么时候失明的？是怎么发生的？”我说：“我不怎么想和陌生人讨论这些。”
And she said, well, I don't know why. You certainly don't have a very Christian attitude. You should be grateful. I've given money to the blind. You should be grateful. I said, you've never given any money to me, lady, and crossed the street to get away from her.
她说：“我不知道为什么。你表现得一点都不像个基督徒。你应该心存感激。我给盲人捐过钱。你应该心存感激。”我说：“女士，你从来没给我捐过一分钱。”说完我就过马路躲开了她。
Now, when I heard this story, I got really excited. And that's because the woman who I've been involved with for the past three years-- her name is Cary LaCheen-- has these sorts of experiences with strangers on the street.
现在，当我听到这个故事时，我非常兴奋。这是因为我过去三年一直在交往的女性——她叫卡莉·拉奇恩——在街上也常遇到这类陌生人。
Sorry, I just can't help myself. I have to pause this again. Could there be a more awkward way to say "my girlfriend" than "the woman I've been involved with for the past three years"? Anyway, my girlfriend, Cary-- who's not blind, by the way.
抱歉，我实在忍不住。我必须再次暂停。还有比“我过去三年一直在交往的女性”更尴尬的说法来称呼“我的女朋友”吗？总之，我的女朋友，卡莉——顺便说一下，她并不是盲人。
She's only got one full arm. Her left arm stops at the elbow. And complete strangers have approached her on the street to ask her what happened to her arm. So I didn't say anything about Cary to Betty at the time. I was just eavesdropping. But I did go home and tell Cary about Betty's story. And her response was--
她只有一只完整的手臂。她的左臂在手肘处就断了。完全陌生的路人会走过来问她手臂发生了什么事。所以当时我没有对贝蒂提关于卡莉的事。我只是在偷听。但我回家后把贝蒂的故事告诉了卡莉。她的反应是——
Shock and excitement of recognition. I've been pretty isolated from other people who are disabled, for a number of complicated reasons, but I just have never been in a position to really trade those stories with anybody or to hear that other people had the same experience that I did.
震惊，以及那种被理解的兴奋。出于各种复杂的原因，我一直与其他残疾人相当隔绝，我从未处于一个能够真正与他人交流这些故事，或者听到其他人也有和我同样经历的处境。
So I decided to try to capture stories like this, true-to-life adventures with strangers approaching disabled people on the street, for other disabled people and for able-bodied people to hear. I talked to five people, including Cary and Betty. Here's Donna Vino.
所以我决定尝试捕捉这样的故事，那些关于陌生人接近残疾人的真实冒险，好让其他残疾人和健全人都能听到。我采访了五个人，包括卡莉和贝蒂。这是唐娜·维诺。
And this one is a series of personal stories, all of them, I'd say, pretty good, told by great, funny talkers. Me, jumping in now and then with narration to point out some bigger lessons that we're supposed to draw from the stories. Playing this for my girlfriend this week-- excuse me-- playing this for the woman I've been involved with for the last year and a half, she had this reaction, which was like, it's clear what you're trying to make and who you want to be, but you're not doing it right.
这系列故事都是个人的亲身经历，我得说，都很棒，是由那些风趣健谈的人讲述的。我会时不时插话进行叙述，指出一些我们应该从故事中汲取的更深刻的教训。这周给我的女朋友放这段录音时——抱歉，是给和我交往了一年半的那位女性放录音时，她的反应是，你试图制作的东西和你想成为的人很明确，但你做的不对。
And I think that's really a good way to put it. I was vaguely stumbling on my way to making the radio show that you are listening to right this second, where people come on and tell personal stories. But at 25, all the moves I make are really clunky. I'm trying so hard. Near the end of the story, when I try to point out some bigger idea from the story, it could not be more didactic.
我觉得这种说法真的很好。我在制作你们此刻正在收听的广播节目的道路上，曾经有些模糊地磕磕绊绊，节目里人们会来讲自己的个人故事。但在25岁时，我所做的一切真的都很笨拙。我太努力了。在故事快结束时，当我试图指出故事中更宏大的观点时，那简直不能更说教了。
Now, if you're an able-bodied person listening to this, I don't want to leave you now with fear somehow or leave you scared that you'll say the wrong thing to some disabled person. Here are three general rules that you can follow. Number one, you shouldn't offer help to someone unless they actually look like they need help. And in that case, you should go up to them and you should ask them first if they want your help.
现在，如果你是一个健全人，听到这里，我不想让你带着恐惧离开，或者担心自己会对某个残疾人说错话。这里有三个你可以遵循的通用规则。第一，除非别人看起来真的需要帮助，否则不要主动提供帮助。如果对方看起来确实需要，你应该走过去先询问他们是否需要你的帮助。
It's really crazy that I thought that it would be necessary to say this after, at that point, 11 minutes of stories where non-disabled people walk up to people with disabilities and make complete jackasses of themselves. Though I have to say, I was surprised, listening back to this recording, how good the interviews are. That part of it I had down.
真疯狂，我竟然觉得有必要说出这些，毕竟在那之前已经播放了11分钟的故事，内容全是健全人走到残疾人面前做出极其愚蠢的行为。不过我得说，回听这段录音时，我很惊讶采访的效果竟然那么好。那一部分我做得很好。
And also, by my sheer desire to entertain. This story was the kickoff to a series of stories about awkward encounters between people with disabilities and non-disabled people. And in my sign-off to the story, you can hear a little bit of how I sound today, yes, but also a little bit of the teenage magician that I had been not that long before this.
而且，我也纯粹是出于想要娱乐大众的欲望。这个故事是一个关于残疾人与健全人之间尴尬邂逅系列故事的开篇。在我的故事结语中，你不仅能听到我今天声音的一点影子，也能听到我不久前作为一个少年魔术师的声音。
This is Ira Glass. I'll be back next week with more true-to-life adventure stories. Music, maestro. Next week, we hear true-to-life adventure stories from dinner parties.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周我会带着更多的真实生活冒险故事回来。音乐，指挥。下周，我们将听到来自晚宴的真实生活冒险故事。
People tend to--
人们倾向于——
OK, then there's a clip from next week's story, and then--
好吧，以上是下周故事的一小段录音，然后——
Tales of embarrassment and inappropriate behavior by able-bodied people, next week on this public radio program.
下周在公共广播节目中，将播出有关健全人尴尬举动和不当行为的故事。
This version of the story ran a month before my 25th birthday, and then another version, minus the organ music, ran on All Things Considered a month after that birthday. At that point, I was not a beginner in radio. I'd been doing radio for six years. And at the time, I really wondered if I ever was going to get it.
这个版本的采访在我25岁生日前一个月播出，而另一个去掉了风琴音乐的版本在我生日过了一个月后在《万事皆备》节目中播出。那时候，我已不是广播新手了。我已经在电台工作了六年。当时我真的怀疑自己是否永远无法掌握要领。
I was a freelancer, and I was so slow at making radio stories that, to earn money, I also worked as a temp secretary. And I would hear the NPR reporters that I admired the most cranking out these perfect little gems of stories in a day or two. And it was like they had some, I don't know, superpower that was somehow unavailable to me, no matter how hard I tried.
我是一名自由职业者，制作广播故事的速度太慢，为了赚钱，我还兼职当临时秘书。我常听到我最钦佩的NPR记者们在一天或两天内就能炮制出这些完美的故事瑰宝。就像他们拥有某种我无论如何努力都无法获得的超能力一样。
At 25, I was still figuring a lot of things out. And I bring this up today because this fall marks the 25th anniversary of our program, This American Life. And rather than spend an hour looking back, it seemed more interesting to do a show about what it means to be 25. Not what it means for a radio show to be 25, because who cares, but what it means for a person to be 25.
25岁时，我还在摸索很多事情。我今天提起这件事，是因为今年秋天是我们节目《此美国生活》开播25周年。与其花一小时回顾过去，做一个关于“25岁意味着什么”的节目似乎更有意思。不是对一个广播节目来说25岁意味着什么，因为那没人在乎，而是对一个人来说25岁意味着什么。
It's such a particular age. You're an adult, but you're new enough to it that it still can feel like you have a long way to go to turn yourself into the person you want to be.
这是一个非常特殊的年纪。你已经成年了，但你对成年生活还很陌生，以至于你会觉得要成为自己想成为的人还有很长的路要走。
So today on our show, we've collected a bunch of stories about all kinds of 25-year-olds-- some of them struggling, some of them focused and accomplished and not struggling at all, and then a couple who are somewhere in between. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
所以今天在我们的节目中，我们收集了各种25岁人的故事——有些人正在挣扎，有些人目标明确、成就斐然，一点也不挣扎，还有几个人处于两者之间。来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《此美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, 29 Versus 19. So our first story in today's program is reported by one of the youngest people on our staff, Noor Gill, who was 25 when she applied for her job here. She is now 26. Hi, Noor.
第一幕，29对19。今天节目中的第一个故事是由我们员工中最年轻的人之一努尔·吉尔报道的，她来这里应聘时才25岁。她现在26岁了。你好，努尔。
Hi, Ira.
你好，艾拉。
So Noor, before you get to the person who you're doing your story about, just take a second and remind older people what it is like to be the young, least experienced person in some workplace.
努尔，在介绍你故事的主人公之前，先花点时间提醒一下年纪大的人，在一个职场中作为最年轻、最没经验的人是什么感觉。
I think it's like, it's scary because you're trying to prove to people that you're not an idiot, but then you think you're an idiot, too. So it's just, it's hard. You worry about the smallest things, like stupid things, like how I would send an email, or like how I'm sitting in my chair. I think you worry about how your coworkers are going to see you. And then you start to realize that no one even cares. I've definitely shown up late, and it made no difference.
我想那很可怕，因为你试图向别人证明你不是个白痴，但有时你又觉得自己就是个白痴。所以，这真的很难。你会担心最小的事情，比如一些愚蠢的事，像我该怎么发电子邮件，或者我坐在椅子上的姿势。我认为你会担心同事们会怎么看你。然后你开始意识到，根本没人关心。我绝对迟到过，但这毫无影响。
Like nobody was paying attention at all.
就像根本没人注意一样。
Everyone else is so busy, no one pays attention. But that's a good thing. Once I realized that, I didn't feel as stressed about every little thing.
每个人都太忙了，没人注意。但这是一件好事。一旦我意识到这一点，我就不会为每一件小事感到那么大的压力了。
OK, so the story that you put together, that people will hear now, it's about somebody who is 25 in the same kind of position that you're in, except in a job where the stakes are higher, right?
好的，那么你整理的故事，大家现在要听到的那个，是关于一个25岁的人，处境和你一样，只是她那份工作的赌注更高，对吗？
Yeah, way higher.
是的，高多了。
All right. Well, take it from here.
好的，那你开始吧。
I came across a profile in The New York Times this summer about a 25-year-old who had a job that seemed very consequential, way more consequential than any I've had. She was a scientist working at the biotech company Regeneron, part of the team racing to find a treatment for COVID, where actual people's lives are on the line. And I remember thinking, she's only 25? How'd she even get that job? Her name is Stephanie Giordano. I wasn't the only person who saw the article and reached out.
今年夏天，我在《纽约时报》上看到了一篇关于一个25岁年轻人的简介，她拥有一份看起来非常有影响力的工作，远比我做过的任何工作都更有分量。她是一名在生物技术公司Regeneron工作的科学家，是竞相寻找新冠治疗方案的团队成员，那里关乎真实的人命。我记得当时心想，她才25岁？她是怎么得到那份工作的？她叫斯蒂芬妮·焦尔达诺。我并不是唯一一个看到这篇文章并与她联系的人。
Yeah, it was like teachers from high school, teachers from college, every single one of my ex-boyfriends' moms.
是的，就像高中的老师、大学的老师，还有我每一位前男友的妈妈。
Oh that's funny.
噢，那真有趣。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Why do you think the boyfriends' moms?
你为什么觉得是前男友们的妈妈？
Not to brag-- no, I'm just saying that-- I won Best to Bring Home to Mom and Dad in high school.
不是在吹嘘——不，我只是说——我在高中时曾获得“最适合带回家见父母”奖。
That's a category?
还有这个奖项？
That was a superlative in my yearbook. Moms love me. But I'm polite.
那是毕业纪念册里的一个最高荣誉。妈妈们爱我。但我很有礼貌。
Stephanie's nice to talk to. She laughs a lot, and she's funny. She has some pink in her hair. Working on a project like this wasn't some huge goal she'd set out for herself. She loved science, but she loves a lot of other stuff, too.
斯蒂芬妮很好聊。她经常笑，而且很风趣。她的头发里染了一点粉色。参与这样一个项目并不是她为自己设定的什么宏大目标。她热爱科学，但她也热爱其他许多东西。
Back in January, she was living in New York City with her roommate and commuting to the suburbs for work at Regeneron's headquarters. And it was then that COVID first became a part of her life, much earlier than for most of us in the US, and long before there were many confirmed cases or anything closed down. She first heard about it at work and didn't think too much of it.
今年一月，她和室友住在纽约市，每天通勤到郊区的Regeneron总部上班。就在那时，新冠第一次走进了她的生活，比美国大多数人都要早得多，且远在出现许多确诊病例或实施封锁之前。她是在工作时第一次听说它的，并没有太在意。
I guess it was like early, mid-January when it became a topic of conversation in the lab, not really in my social spheres or with anyone outside of the lab. Honestly in the beginning, it was just sort of chatting. It was like, let's just keep an eye on it and see how it spreads. It was really just a side idea at the time. And then it got really intense.
我想大概是在一月中旬或下旬，它开始成为实验室里的谈资，而不是在我的社交圈或实验室外的人当中。老实说，起初这只是随口聊聊。就像是，我们留心观察一下，看看它如何传播。当时这确实只是一个边缘议题。然后情况变得非常紧张。
Regeneron has thousands of employees working on all sorts of things. Stephanie happened to sit right between the two people in her department who were spearheading the COVID project. Kristen, the lead, sat next to her.
Regeneron有数千名员工在做各种各样的事情。斯蒂芬妮正好坐在她部门里负责新冠项目的两个人之间。领导者克里斯汀坐在她旁边。
And then right behind me was Vincenzo, who was also on the rapid response team.
然后就在我身后是文森佐，他也是快速反应小组的成员。
The rapid response team wasn't working on a vaccine. They were making a drug to treat people who got COVID and help them recover. The idea was to make a cocktail of different antibodies to neutralize the virus.
快速反应小组研究的不是疫苗。他们在制造一种药物来治疗感染新冠的病人，帮助他们康复。想法是制造一种不同的抗体鸡尾酒来中和病毒。
Kristen and Vincenzo were talking about the plan constantly across Stephanie's desk, and Stephanie couldn't help but overhear. But she was busy with her own assignments, until one night-- this was still back in January, early in the outbreak-- when she was getting ready to take the 5:30 shuttle bus to her train back to the city. She saw Kristen and Vincenzo were in for another late night, and offered to stay back and help.
克里斯汀和文森佐不断地在斯蒂芬妮的办公桌对面讨论方案，斯蒂芬妮忍不住听到了。但她正忙于自己的任务，直到一个晚上——那时还是在一月，疫情爆发初期——当她准备搭乘5点30分的班车赶火车回城时。她看到克里斯汀和文森佐又要通宵工作了，便主动留下帮忙。
I saw if another set of hands were there, it meant that they can go home at 8:00 PM instead of 9:30 PM. At that point, I didn't realize that one day would probably be a lot longer than just one day of taking the later shuttle.
我看到如果多一双手，他们就能在晚上8点而不是9点半回家。当时，我没意识到那一天可能会比仅仅多搭一次晚班车要漫长得多。
Raising your hand to be the one who stays late? This is something we know how to do at 25. I'm very familiar with this move. Within a few days, Stephanie had dropped all her other projects and was working full-time on the COVID treatment. Her team's project was to come up with a way to quickly screen which antibodies actually worked against the virus.
主动举手说要留下来加班？这是我们25岁时就知道怎么做的事。我对这种做法非常熟悉。几天之内，斯蒂芬妮就放下了所有其他项目，全职投入到新冠治疗的研究中。她团队的任务是想出一种方法，快速筛选出哪些抗体能真正对抗病毒。
As part of that project, Stephanie's assignment was to make what she calls a virus-like particle, a fake version of the coronavirus that could infect cells. It came down to testing hundreds of different recipes, getting the conditions exactly right. She was working long hours, lots of weekends as the team rushed to get the project in place. Her job was slowly becoming her entire life.
作为该项目的一部分，斯蒂芬妮的任务是制造她所说的类病毒颗粒，一种能感染细胞的新冠病毒假版本。这归结为测试数百种不同的配方，精确地调整各种条件。她工作时间很长，当团队争分夺秒推进项目时，很多周末也在加班。她的工作慢慢变成了她的全部生活。
At some point in February, months before anyone was wearing masks, before COVID was even officially a pandemic, she started to get nervous riding the packed train every day to work. So in March, she moved from her apartment in Manhattan to a temporary place near Regeneron's headquarters and threw herself fully into the project.
二月的某个时候，在任何人戴口罩之前，在新冠被正式定义为大流行之前，她开始害怕每天乘坐拥挤的火车去上班。所以到了三月，她从曼哈顿的公寓搬到了Regeneron总部附近的一个临时住处，完全投身于这个项目中。
I was so excited. Yeah, it was just like a pretty huge undertaking. It was a little sad. I felt really weird leaving the city. I felt weird.
我太兴奋了。是的，这就像是一个相当巨大的事业。这有点悲伤。我觉得离开城市感觉很奇怪。我感觉很怪异。
I couldn't see anyone. So I didn't see my boyfriend for like almost two months. And it felt really-- it felt really hard to prioritize what, at the time, was just my job, just putting my job before a lot of things that I normally prioritize. But I just knew that in my heart, that this was going to be something much more important.
我见不到任何人。所以我大概有两个月没见到我的男朋友。这感觉真的——把当时仅是一份工作的任务优先于我通常重视的许多事情，感觉真的很困难。但我心里清楚，这将会是一件意义重大得多的事情。
After that, every day she'd wake up in her empty Airbnb, drive the seven minutes it took to get to the lab, spent hours each day alone in that lab that had to be kept dark, staring into a microscope. She'd stay there until around 10:00 or later, only to drive back and do it all over again.
在那之后，她每天在空荡荡的Airbnb里醒来，开七分钟的车到达实验室，每天独自在那个必须保持黑暗的实验室里待上几个小时，盯着显微镜看。她会待到晚上10点左右或更晚，然后开车回去，第二天循环往复。
It was just really lonely. I hadn't ever lived alone without any roommates before, so that was really weird. It was really quiet.
真的太孤独了。我以前从未独自住过，没有任何室友，所以这真的很奇怪。太安静了。
Was there a day or a week that it was just so lonely that you thought maybe you couldn't do this anymore?
有没有哪一天或哪一周让你感到如此孤独，以至于你觉得可能再也坚持不下去了？
I just remember being up at 1:30 in the morning, and the TV in the bedroom-- I didn't really know how to use the remote because I never really watched it. And I just turned it on, and it was on PBS. And it was LCD Soundsystem's live recording from like 2012, and it just made me incredibly sad.
我只记得有一次凌晨1点30分，卧室里的电视——我不太会用遥控器，因为我平时不看电视。我就打开它，刚好调到了公共电视网。那是LCD Soundsystem 2012年的现场录音，这让我感到无比悲伤。
And then they played the song "All My Friends," which is just this song about no matter what, at the end of the day, whatever happens, you have the people in your life, and they're always going to be with you. Here I was in this apartment alone, doing God knows what. I haven't seen anyone I love or care about, and I don't know the next time that I will. And I was just watching. I just started hysterically crying, which is really dramatic, but I think that was probably the lowest moment.
然后他们放了《All My Friends》这首歌，这首歌讲的是无论发生什么，到最后，无论发生了什么，你身边都有你生命中的人，他们会永远和你在一起。而我一个人在这个公寓里，做着天知道是什么的工作。我没见过任何我爱或关心的人，也不知道下次见到他们是什么时候。我只是看着。我开始歇斯底里地大哭，这真的很戏剧化，但我觉得那可能是我最落魄的时刻。
Meanwhile, outside of Stephanie's Airbnb and the lab, things were turning for the worst. Hospitals in New York worried about having enough PPE. The schools, restaurants, and bars started shutting down. There was one moment during those first few intense months of work that stood out to Stephanie. It was when she finally got one of the first key steps in the experiment to work.
与此同时，在斯蒂芬妮的Airbnb和实验室之外，情况正在恶化。纽约的医院担心个人防护装备不足。学校、餐馆和酒吧开始关闭。在那最初几个月紧张工作中，有一个瞬间让斯蒂芬妮印象深刻。那是她终于使实验的关键步骤之一成功的那一刻。
She was testing to see if her virus-like particles, the fake viruses, were infecting cells and acting like the real thing. To do this, she designed an experiment that would cause cells to glow green if they were infected. She spent days trying to get the conditions right. And then one day--
她正在测试她的类病毒颗粒，也就是假病毒，是否正在感染细胞并表现得像真病毒一样。为了做到这一点，她设计了一个实验，如果细胞被感染，就会发出绿光。她花了几天时间试图调整出正确的条件。然后有一天——
Oh, my god. I was on the Zeiss, one of our microscopes here. And you can scan the whole plate, and it's like 3,000 images. And I just remember it hit like 1,500, and I saw green. And I was like [GASPS]. And I just ran out of the room and found my boss. And I was like, I think it worked.
噢，天哪。我当时正用显微镜。你可以扫描整个板子，大约有3000张图像。我记得扫到第1500张时，我看到了绿色。我当时就像[倒吸一口气]。我直接跑出房间找到了我的老板。我说，我觉得成功了。
How did your boss react?
你老板有什么反应？
I think everyone else was like, yeah, it works. Of course, it works. But for me, I was like, but it worked when I did it.
我觉得其他人就像是，噢，成功了。当然会成功。但对我来说，我是觉得，但我做的时候它成功了。
When you're new and not used to things going right, even getting the smallest thing to work out can feel huge. Getting those cells to light up green was just a tiny step in a thousand other steps that ultimately worked out. Regeneron started testing their antibody cocktail in June. It was one of the treatments President Trump got back in October, and it was just approved to be used in emergencies by the FDA last month. It's not a cure-all, but the treatment has been shown to help some high-risk patients.
当你是个新人，不习惯事情顺利进行时，即使是最小的事情获得成功也感觉意义重大。让那些细胞发出绿光只是最终成功的一千个步骤中的一小步。Regeneron在六月开始测试他们的抗体鸡尾酒疗法。这就是特朗普总统在十月接受的治疗之一，并且在上个月刚刚获得FDA批准用于紧急使用。它不是万能药，但这种疗法已被证明能帮助一些高危患者。
Do you ever feel like-- this is going to be a sports analogy-- but like you're a rookie who played a couple innings on a team that won the World Series? Do you ever feel like that?
你有没有觉得——这是一个体育比喻——你就像一个在赢得世界大赛的球队里打了两局球的新秀？你有过那种感觉吗？
Oh, yeah, absolutely. Yeah, that's actually a really good way to put it. I guess, to stick with the sports analogy, a lot of the time in big meetings and stuff, I would be on the sidelines, listening in. And even if it was data I helped generate, I'd still be like, wow, who put that together? That looks amazing.
噢，有的，绝对有。是的，那实际上是一个很好的比喻。我想，继续用体育比喻的话，很多时候在大会议之类的地方，我会在场边旁听。即使是我帮助生成的数据，我依然会觉得，哇，是谁把它拼凑在一起的？那看起来太棒了。
You're so modest, Stephanie.
你太谦虚了，斯蒂芬妮。
I wish I could be like-- I think I can fluctuate between thinking I am a god-- not really, but being like, wow, I look awesome. I'm doing awesome. I got a 401(k).
我希望我能表现得像——我觉得我会在“觉得自己是个神”——当然不是真的，但会想，哇，我看起来太棒了。我做得太棒了。我还有401(k)养老金。
Yeah, that's better than me.
是啊，那比我强多了。
And then I'm like, oh, I'm just a regular idiot, just trying to figure [INAUDIBLE].
然后我就又觉得，噢，我只是个普通的白痴，只是试图弄明白[听不清]。
Do you think this is going to be the biggest thing you'll ever do in your life?
你觉得这会是你一生中做过的最伟大的事情吗？
It's kind of sad to think of it like that, but I can't imagine anything else being as impactful. Hopefully, it doesn't end here.
这样想有点悲伤，但我无法想象还有什么事情能有这么大的影响力。希望这一切不会到此结束。
So it's not all downhill from here?
所以以后不会走下坡路吗？
It might be. Maybe I have a quarter-life crisis and let myself go. I don't know. But I hope not. I'm hopeful about it.
可能会吧。也许我会经历一场四分之一人生危机，然后放任自流。我不知道。但我希望不会。我对此抱有希望。
She told me she knows she isn't some super genius. A lot of scientists could have done what she did. She just happened to be in the right place at the right time.
她告诉我，她知道自己并不是什么超级天才。很多科学家都能做到她所做的。她只是碰巧在正确的时间出现在了正确的地方。
Noor Gill is the production fellow of our show.
努尔·吉尔是我们节目的制作研究员。
Act Two, Buy Like A Butterfly. So we turn next to another 25-year-old who's already achieved some things in her life-- in fact, achieved at a level that most of us never get to, even when we're older. Her name is Claressa Shields, and she has won two Olympic gold medals in women's boxing. And in addition to that, all kinds of other championship titles, and belts, and accolades.
第二幕，像蝴蝶一样购买。所以接下来转向另一位25岁的年轻人，她已经在生活中取得了一些成就——事实上，取得的成就水平是我们大多数人在年纪大时都无法企及的。她的名字叫克拉丽莎·希尔兹，她赢得了两枚女子拳击奥运金牌。除此之外，还有各种各样的其他冠军头衔、金腰带和赞誉。
But this year, this year at 25, her big accomplishment was different. With boxing shut down for COVID, she bought a house. She bought a house on the outskirts of her hometown, Flint, Michigan.
但是今年，今年25岁的她，最大的成就是不同的。由于疫情导致拳击比赛停摆，她买了一栋房子。她在自己家乡密歇根州弗林特市的郊区买了一栋房子。
Sue Jaye Johnson has known Claressa for almost a decade. She made a radio story about Claressa with the documentary series Radio Diaries, and then produced a film about her called T-Rex, Her Fight for Gold. She got in touch again with Claressa to ask about this latest achievement.
苏·杰伊·约翰逊认识克拉丽莎快十年了。她曾为纪录片系列《广播日记》制作过关于克拉丽莎的广播故事，后来还制作了一部关于她的电影《霸王龙：她的金牌之战》。她再次联系了克拉丽莎，询问她这一最新成就。
The idea of Claressa owning a house is wild to me, because I've known her since she was 16. I met her at a boxing tournament in 2011. I was photographing and interviewing the women who were competing to be on the first-ever Olympic team for women's boxing. It was Claressa's first adult tournament, and she made heads turn.
克拉丽莎拥有房子的想法对我来说太疯狂了，因为我从她16岁时就认识她了。我是在2011年的一场拳击比赛中遇到她的。我当时正在拍摄并采访那些为了成为史上首支奥运女子拳击队成员而参赛的女性。那是克拉丽莎参加的第一次成人比赛，她吸引了所有人的目光。
Claressa Shields!
克拉丽莎·希尔兹！
She was faster and stronger than any other boxer, but what really caught my attention was this determined look in her eyes. That, and the way she thumped her chest when she won, like she was already the greatest. Claressa's one of my favorite people. It's been a privilege to have a front row seat on her life all these years, including this new chapter.
她比任何其他拳手都更快、更强，但真正吸引我注意的是她眼中那种坚定的神情。还有她获胜时拍打胸口的样子，就像她已经是世上最伟大的人一样。克拉丽莎是我最喜欢的人之一。这些年来能以前排座席见证她的人生，包括这一新篇章，是一种荣幸。
Ever since she was 16, she told me she wanted two things-- a gold medal-- she got her first one a year later-- and a house, a safe place for her and her family.
从16岁起，她就告诉我她想要两样东西——一枚金牌——她一年后就拿到了第一枚——还有一个家，一个能让她和家人感到安全的地方。
All right.
好的。
She gave me a little tour of it on FaceTime.
她在FaceTime上带我稍微参观了一下。
So here we are at my house. This is my fireplace here. On top of my fireplace I have, of course, my TV. Then I have the 2020 Barbie doll of the year.
这是我的房子。这是我的壁炉。在壁炉上方当然放着我的电视。然后我还有2020年年度芭比娃娃。
[BEEP]
[哔]
That's my smoke detector. I haven't changed the batteries.
那是我的烟雾探测器。我还没换电池。
It's nice. Not massive, but big. Brick and gray vinyl siding with generous windows, a two-car garage. It's got three bedrooms. A Jacuzzi in the master bathroom, which was a big selling point. She says when she first saw the living room, she thought she'd need three or four couches to fill the space. There's also a pool in the back that she says can fit about 20 people, and a yard. In the dining room, a long, welcoming table set for eight. And at the head of it, a hint of her royalty.
房子很漂亮。不算巨大，但也不小。砖块和灰色乙烯基壁板，明亮宽敞的窗户，一个双车位车库。有三个卧室。主卫里有一个按摩浴缸，这是一个很大的卖点。她说当她第一次看到客厅时，她觉得需要三四个沙发才能填满那个空间。后面还有一个泳池，她说能容纳约20个人，还有一个院子。餐厅里有一张长长的、好客的餐桌，摆着八个座位。在餐桌的主位上，隐约可见她身为女王的傲气。
The queen chair is down there. That's my chair. All the other chairs don't even have the studded diamonds. That one does.
那把女王椅在那儿。那是我的椅子。其他所有椅子甚至都没有镶钻。只有那把有。
You have a chair studded with real diamonds?
你有一把镶着真钻的椅子？
Why not, Sue?
为什么不呢，苏？
Because you have a throne. I don't know. Who thinks of that?
因为你有个王座。我不知道。谁会想到这个？
It's only two chairs. It's only two chairs, so it didn't cost that much. And then we come over here where I have my trophy case, which I only got one more drawer to fill.
只有两把椅子。只有两把，所以没花多少钱。然后我们走到这边，这是我的奖杯陈列柜，我只剩一个抽屉就能填满了。
Turning 25, the most exciting thing that I've done is buy my house. I'm like a big person with numbers. So 25-- 2 plus 5 is 7, and 7 is my favorite number. So I knew that something special would happen at 25 in my life, but I just didn't see me buying a house. It all just kind of just happened. I just feel like it's the opposite of what I grew up in.
25岁时，我做的最激动人心的事情就是买了我的房子。我喜欢数字。25——2加5等于7，而7是我最喜欢的数字。所以我知道25岁时我的生活中会发生一些特别的事情，只是没想到会是买房。这一切就这样发生了。我觉得这跟我成长环境完全相反。
Claressa never had a solid home for very long growing up. She lived at something like a dozen addresses before she was 17, had to deal with all kinds of abuse and deprivation. And it started early. She was moved out of her mom's place when she was five.
克拉丽莎成长过程中从未拥有过稳定的家。她在17岁前搬过十几次家，不得不应付各种虐待和匮乏。而且这很早就开始了。她5岁时就搬离了妈妈家。
And I lived with my grandmother to the age of nine. And all this time I spent away from my younger brothers and my sisters. Also, too, moving back in with my mom abusing alcohol. And moved out from with my mom and moved in with my coach, Jason. That was my decision.
我9岁前都和祖母住在一起。这段时间我一直没能和我的弟弟妹妹们在一起。而且，搬回有酗酒问题的妈妈那里住，后来我又决定从妈妈那里搬出来，住进了教练杰森家里。这是我自己的决定。
Jason and his wife, Mickey. Claressa calls her Mama Mickey. That was when she was 17, the first time she had her own bed, her own room. She was there a little more than a year, then started living on her own. Lived in Colorado for a couple years, in Florida for a couple more. Always rented, so now, having an entire house of her own, it's a big deal.
杰森和他的妻子米奇。克拉丽莎叫她米奇妈妈。那是她17岁的时候，第一次拥有了自己的床，自己的房间。她在那里待了一年多，然后就开始独自生活。在科罗拉多住了几年，又在佛罗里达住了几年。一直租房，所以现在，拥有了一整栋属于自己的房子，这是一件大事。
And I have to say, I've had some great moments in my life, as I am a two-time Olympic gold medalist, and nine-time world champion, and three division world champion faster than any other male boxer in history-- any other boxer in history, period.
我得说，我生命中经历过一些伟大的时刻，作为两届奥运金牌得主、九届世界冠军、三级别世界冠军，我是史上获胜速度最快的男拳手——等等，史上最快的拳手，句号。
But when I got the keys to my house, it was this overwhelming feeling of joy and internal happiness of knowing that I'll never be homeless ever again in my life. I'll never have to worry about where I'm going to live. My family, if they need somewhere to come stay, if I can't find them somewhere to stay, I always have an extra room for them. And it just gave me this whole sense of just like, you really grown now.
但当我拿到钥匙时，那是一种压倒性的喜悦和内心的幸福，因为我知道我这辈子再也不会无家可归了。我不必再担心住在哪里。如果我的家人需要地方住，如果我找不到其他地方，我总有一个备用房间留给他们。这让我有一种真正的成年感。
I have a therapist now, just to help me deal with the stress of not being able to fight.
我现在有心理咨询师了，只是为了帮我应对因为无法参赛而产生的压力。
All of her fights were cancelled this year because of coronavirus. She says it's been really hard on her.
今年因为新冠病毒，她所有的比赛都被取消了。她说这对她打击很大。
Because I'm used to fighting all the time, and being on TV, and always being on the go. And it's like having to deal with all the trolls on Instagram and Twitter, and just deal with life in general, and how to express my emotions not with anger, and not with tears, and not sink into depression. Depression has got too hard to deal with by myself, so that's 25-year-old decisions, putting yourself in therapy. Yeah.
因为我习惯了一直比赛，出现在电视上，总是忙个不停。现在就像必须处理Instagram和Twitter上所有的喷子，处理生活中的琐事，学习如何不带着愤怒、不流泪地表达情绪，不陷入抑郁。抑郁症太难靠自己应对了，所以这是25岁的决定，让自己接受心理咨询。是的。
I couldn't imagine me at 17 owning a house. It just wouldn't work out. I would throw parties all the time. [LAUGHS]
我无法想象17岁的我买房会是什么样。肯定行不通。我会整天开派对。[笑声]
To paraphrase Corinthians, when Claressa was a kid, she had the dreams of a kid. She told me when she was 16 that she wanted to have 10 children by the age of 26, not factoring in the difficult math of that or how 10 pregnancies might affect her boxing career. She laughs about that now, but the spirit of that dream has stayed with her-- surrounding herself with family, being a protector.
套用哥林多前书的话说，当克拉丽莎是个孩子时，她怀揣着孩子的梦想。她16岁时告诉我，她想在26岁前生10个孩子，没考虑过这背后的数学难题，或者10次怀孕会如何影响她的拳击生涯。她现在对此付之一笑，但那种梦想的精神一直伴随着她——周围环绕着家人，成为保护者。
And slowly, the details became more realistic. She thought winning the gold medals would lead to a bunch of endorsement deals and that she could buy a house not just for herself, but for her mom, preferably somewhere other than Flint, which can be pretty rough. But the endorsements didn't materialize. So she made the transition from the amateurs to the pros, started earning a steady living as a boxer. And she thought she could at least convince her family to move away with her, which is why it was surprising to me that she wound up with a house in Flint.
渐渐地，细节变得更现实了。她以为赢得金牌会带来一堆代言合同，她可以不仅为自己，也为妈妈买房，最好是离开弗林特，因为那地方环境比较恶劣。但代言并没有实现。于是她从业余转向职业，开始以拳手身份赚取稳定收入。她以为自己至少能说服家人和她一起搬走，这也是为什么她最终在弗林特买房让我感到惊讶。
I remember the goal that you had was to get out of Flint.
我记得你的目标是离开弗林特。
Mhm.
嗯。
That was one of the reasons why you wanted to get the gold medal, so that you and your family could get out of Flint, is you wouldn't have to live there.
那是你想要获得金牌的原因之一，为了让你和家人能离开弗林特，这样你就不用住在那里了。
I just know I wanted a better life for myself. I wanted to be more financially stable. I wanted to have food, a bed. So I don't really think it was not being in Flint. I think it was more of like, I just don't want to be poor.
我只是知道我想要更好的生活。我想在财务上更稳定。我想有食物，有一张床。所以我觉得这不是离开弗林特的问题。我觉得更多是，我只是不想再穷下去了。
And what about getting your family out? You used to talk a lot about getting your family out of Flint, like keep them safe.
那么带着家人离开呢？你以前常说要带家人离开弗林特，保护他们安全。
Over time, I've also tried that. When I moved to Florida, my younger brother moved with me. But my younger sister and my mother wouldn't come. It was like, all right, so now I'm just in Florida with none of my family, except my little brother. Can y'all be quiet a little bit?
随着时间推移，我也试过。我搬到佛罗里达时，我弟弟跟我去了。但妹妹和妈妈不肯来。当时的情况是，好了，现在我独自在佛罗里达，没家人陪，只有弟弟。你们能不能安静一点？
While we were talking, four of Claressa's nieces were huddled together on the big, gray sectional sofa in the living room. Her nieces and nephews are over a lot these days, playing video games, jumping in the pool. She's strict with them sometimes when the house gets messy. She makes her nephew, Fat Daddy, do the vacuuming.
在我们交谈时，克拉丽莎的四个侄女缩在客厅里的大灰色沙发上。她的侄子侄女们经常过来，打游戏，在泳池里玩耍。有时候家里乱的时候她会对他们很严格。她让侄子“肥爸”去用吸尘器打扫。
But she likes having them all there. And there aren't 10 of them, there are 11. She's filled her house with a bevy of kids like she wanted, just not in the way she expected, which is true generally for her at the moment. The life she has now with the house in Flint? It's not what she imagined, but it fits all her needs and desires. It's what boxers do. They respond to what's thrown at them, and they adjust.
但她喜欢他们都在这里。虽然没有10个，只有11个。她如愿以偿地把房子填满了孩子，只是方式与预期不同，这对于现在的她来说普遍适用。她现在在弗林特的这个家？这不是她想象中的样子，但满足了她所有的需求和渴望。这就是拳手所做的。他们应对掷向他们的东西，然后做出调整。
But she says, this isn't the end. She still has big dreams. In fact, she just announced that she signed a multi-year deal to be a mixed martial arts fighter, where the money is better for women. She wants to buy a second house, a mansion in Vegas.
但她说，这还没结束。她还有宏大的梦想。事实上，她刚刚宣布签署了一份为期多年的协议，成为一名综合格斗选手，那里给女性的薪水更高。她想买第二栋房子，在维加斯买栋豪宅。
Sue Jaye Johnson. She's a writer and filmmaker. Her film T-Rex, about Claressa's journey to the Olympics, you can find at PBS.org. Coming up, a woman at 25 who decides, after years of saying no to her parents about something, to try it their way for once. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
苏·杰伊·约翰逊。她是一位作家和电影制作人。关于克拉丽莎奥运之旅的电影《霸王龙》可以在PBS.org上找到。稍后播出，一位25岁的女性决定，在多年来拒绝父母的某些要求后，第一次尝试他们的方式。这是来自芝加哥公共电台的节目，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, 25. To commemorate our 25th year on the air, we have stories today about people, human beings, who were created the same year as our program. We have stories of 25-year-olds.
这里是《此美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，25岁。为了纪念我们开播25周年，我们今天准备了关于人类的故事，关于那些和我们的节目诞生于同一年的人。我们有关于25岁年轻人的故事。
And I just want to note, before we go to the next story, that the one other thing that we have done to mark our 25th year is that we set up a web page with a list of favorite episodes from over the years. It has the very easy to remember address, thisamericanlife.org/25years. And if you go there, you'll see a mix of audience favorites, but also some deep cuts I bet you have never heard or you probably don't remember if you did hear.
在我进入下一个故事之前，我只想说明，为了纪念25周年我们所做的另一件事是，我们建立了一个网页，列出了多年来我们最喜欢的剧集。地址非常容易记住，thisamericanlife.org/25years。如果你去那里，你会看到观众最喜爱的内容，但也包括一些我敢说你从未听说过，或者即使听过可能也不记得的深度剪辑。
My personal suggestion among those, OK, is the show called "I am From the Private Sector and I'm Here to Help," where Nancy Updike takes you into this world of not the American military, but the private contractors who worked alongside the military in Baghdad in 2004. And the episode is part-- I don't know-- like The Office or Veep, and part a war. There are lots of other shows in addition to that one ready for your holiday listening while you're cooking, or shopping online, or whatever. Anyway, thisamericanlife.org/25years.
其中我个人的推荐，好的，是那期名为“我来自私营部门，我是来帮忙的”，南希·厄普代克带你进入的不是美军世界，而是2004年巴格达与军队并肩工作的私营承包商世界。那期节目部分——我不知道——就像是《办公室》或《副总统》，部分是战争。除了那一个，还有许多其他节目准备好供你假期烹饪、在线购物或做任何事时收听。总之，thisamericanlife.org/25years。
And with that, we have arrived at Act Three of our show-- Act Three, The Rest of His Life. So some of us here at the radio show read this essay back in June that really got to us that Mitchell S. Jackson wrote about a 25-year-old. The essay's about Ahmaud Arbery, who was 25 when he was pursued by three white men in Georgia and shot to death while out for a run. The essay was published in Runner's World magazine. And as you'll hear, it leans into the running parts of things just a little bit, but it's also so much more than that.
就这样，我们到达了节目的第三幕——第三幕，他的余生。我们电台的一些人今年六月读了米切尔·S·杰克逊写的这篇真正打动我们的散文，是关于一位25岁年轻人的。散文是关于阿莫德·阿伯里，他在去跑步时被佐治亚州三名白人男子追赶并枪杀，遇害时25岁。这篇散文发表在《跑步者世界》杂志上。正如你即将听到的，它稍微涉及了一些跑步相关的内容，但它所蕴含的意义远不止于此。
Mitchell talked to Ahmaud's closest friends and his family members to create a portrait of Ahmaud Arbery that is really unlike anything else we had seen about him. We asked Mitchell to adapt a version of his essay for our program today. Here he is.
米切尔与阿莫德最亲密的朋友和家人谈过，创作了一幅关于阿莫德·阿伯里的肖像，这与我们之前看到的任何关于他的内容都截然不同。我们请米切尔为今天的节目改编了他的文章。他来了。
Ahmaud Arbery, by all accounts, loved to run. But he wasn't, by his own account, a runner. There's no evidence of Maud training for 10Ks, or full or half marathons, or obsessing over his miles or PR times, but he loved it. Maud would run in a white T-shirt and khaki shorts. He'd run shirtless in basketball shorts. He'd run in a tank top and hoop shoes. As his day-one homeboy, Keem, sums it, he could run in anything.
据所有人所说，阿莫德·阿伯里热爱跑步。但据他自己所说，他并不是一名跑者。没有任何证据表明阿莫德会训练参加10公里跑、半马或全马，或者执着于里程数和个人最好成绩，但他就是爱跑。阿莫德会穿一件白色T恤和卡其色短裤跑步。他会光着膀子穿篮球短裤跑步。他会穿着背心和球鞋跑步。正如他从小到大的铁哥们基姆所总结的那样，他穿什么都能跑。
When Keem was home from college, he and Maud would cruise to one end of the longest-spanning bridge in all of Georgia. They'd do some warm-up stretching and jaunt back and forth across it, a distance of just under 3 miles. The pair would keep a steady pace. But sometimes, Keem says, Maud would push him.
基姆从大学回家时，他和阿莫德会驱车前往佐治亚州最长跨海大桥的一端。他们会做一些热身拉伸，然后在桥上往返慢跑，总距离不到3英里。两人会保持稳定的配速。但基姆说，有时阿莫德会催促他。
On February 23 of this year, Maud went out for a run. The location of this run was a subdivision in Glynn County called Satilla Shores. It's a neighborhood of waterfront properties, of upper and middle-class families, of retired folk and fresh transplants. No one can know for sure the route he took before reaching Satilla Shores, but he'd set off from his home. So that means there's a good chance that on his run, he passed homes flying a Confederate flag or the "Don't Tread on Me" Gadsden flag, and hella homes warning "No Trespassing."
今年的2月23日，阿莫德出去跑步了。这次跑步的地点是格林县一个叫萨蒂拉海岸的社区。这是一个拥有滨水房产的社区，居住着中上层家庭、退休人员和新移民。没有人能确信他在到达萨蒂拉海岸前走的路线，但他是从家里出发的。所以这意味着他跑步时很有可能经过飘扬着邦联旗或“别踩我”加兹登旗的房子，以及许多警告“禁止擅自闯入”的家。
On February 23 when Maud went jogging, he was dressed in light-colored low-top Nikes, a white T-shirt, and khaki cargo shorts. Maud, who was 25 years old, jogged alone.
2月23日阿莫德慢跑时，他穿着浅色的低帮耐克鞋、一件白色T恤和卡其色工装短裤。阿莫德，25岁，独自慢跑。
Maud's family home in Brunswick, the one where he lived at the time he was killed, is a mere 2 miles from Satailla Shores. But in meaningful ways, it's almost another country. Matter of fact, the poverty rate of what young Black residents call The Wick is a staggering 38%.
阿莫德在不伦瑞克的家，也就是他遇害时居住的地方，距离萨蒂拉海岸仅2英里。但在意义上，那几乎是另一个国家。事实上，年轻黑人居民所说的“灯芯”地区的贫困率高达38%。
The Wick is where Ahmaud Marquez Arbery was born on May 8, 1994. He was the third beloved child of Wanda Cooper-Jones and Marcus Arbery, Sr. Their working-class family included his older brother Marcus Buck, Jr., and sister Jasmine. The family called Ahmaud, Quez, a shortened version of his middle name, while his friends called him Maud.
“灯芯”是阿莫德·马尔克斯·阿伯里于1994年5月8日出生的地方。他是万达·库珀-琼斯和老马库斯·阿伯里深爱的第三个孩子。他们的工薪阶层家庭还包括他哥哥小马库斯·巴克和姐姐贾斯敏。家人称阿莫德为奎兹，这是他中间名的缩写，而朋友们叫他阿莫德。
Maud had a slight gap in his front teeth and dark skin forever burnished by hours outside. When Maud was in middle school, the family moved to a small, white house on Boykin Ridge Drive, where Maud continued to share a room with his brother. Per his big bro, Buck, Maud was the slob.
阿莫德的前门牙有一点缝隙，深色的皮肤因在户外活动而永远泛着光。阿莫德读初中时，全家搬到了博伊金岭大道上一栋白色的小房子，在那里阿莫德继续和哥哥合住一间房。据他大哥巴克说，阿莫德是个懒汉。
In high school, Maud landed a gig at the local McDonald's. He did it to keep some scratch in his pocket, but also to help his mother, who often worked two jobs. Some days, Maud's homeboy, Keem, would swoop in from work and wheel them to the Golden Isles YMCA. They would hoop or work out for six or seven hours straight before bopping over to the Glynn Place Mall for the fries and wing combo at American Deli, and heading right back for beaucoup hours more of playing and training. Back then, Maud favored slim jeans, bright-colored polos and rugbys, and kept his hair shorn low with the crispiest of edge-ups.
在高中时，阿莫德在当地的麦当劳找了份活儿。他这么做是为了兜里有点钱，但也为了帮经常打两份工的母亲。有时，阿莫德的铁哥们基姆会下班开车接他们去金群岛基督教青年会。他们会连续打球或健身六七个小时，然后蹦到格林广场商场去吃美国熟食店的薯条和鸡翅套餐，接着回去继续练习。那时，阿莫德喜欢修身牛仔裤、亮色马球衫和橄榄球衫，总是剪着非常干练的超短发，边缘修剪得极其工整。
Maud played football from the peewee league through high school, and ended up an undersized varsity linebacker. But he was also a team captain who led his Brunswick High School Pirates in pre-game chants. Though never cock-diesel strong, Maud owned a super-hearted fearlessness on the field and often astonished his coaches with big hits, and his senior year, made the storied Florida-Georgia War of the Border all-star game.
阿莫德从少儿联盟一直到高中都在打橄榄球，最终成为一名体型偏小的校队后卫。但他也是一位领袖，带领不伦瑞克高中海盗队进行赛前呐喊。虽然算不上肌肉强壮，但阿莫德在赛场上拥有一种极其勇敢无畏的精神，经常以凶狠的撞击让教练们惊叹，高三那年，他入选了著名的佛罗里达-佐治亚边界战争全明星赛。
Not to mention, this was South Georgia football, so Maud competed in a league that produced pros and played before some of the biggest high school football crowds in the country. Before he was an all-star, though, Maud tore his ACL and meniscus in a JV game. While a less dedicated player might have given up, he committed to a laborious rehab. His junior year, he wore a leg brace, a hindrance that diminished his chance of playing in college.
别提了，这可是南佐治亚州的橄榄球赛，所以阿莫德参加的联赛不仅培养职业选手，而且现场观看的高中球赛观众人数在全国也是数一数二的。然而，在成为全明星之前，阿莫德在预备队比赛中撕裂了前十字韧带和半月板。虽然不那么专注的球员可能会放弃，但他坚持进行了艰苦的康复训练。高二那年，他带着护膝，这个障碍减少了他大学打球的机会。
Like Maud, I was a passionate high school athlete. My sport was hoop. Like Maud, no major college program offered me a scholarship. Both Maud and me attended small schools in our home state. Maud quit after a year and returned to Brunswick and his mother's home. I, too, quit my first community college. But unlike Maud, there was no need to return home to my mother's cramped apartment, as I was living there all the while.
像阿莫德一样，我是一名充满激情的大学运动员。我的运动是篮球。像阿莫德一样，没有任何大型大学项目给我提供奖学金。阿莫德和我都在各自家乡的小学校读书。他一年后就退学回到不伦瑞克回到了母亲家中。我也退学了我的第一所社区大学。但与阿莫德不同，我不需要回到母亲那拥挤的公寓，因为我一直住在那儿。
The year after he graduated, Maud was arrested for carrying a gun and sentenced to five years of probation, which he violated by shoplifting. A few years after I graduated high school, I was arrested with drugs and a gun, and sentenced to 16 months in an Oregon state prison.
毕业后一年，阿莫德因携带枪支被捕并被判处五年缓刑，后来因入店行窃违反了缓刑规定。我高中毕业几年后，因毒品和枪支被捕，被判处16个月的俄勒冈州州立监狱刑期。
At 25, Maud was a runner who had every reason to believe his life had more miles ahead of him than behind him. At 25, I enrolled in the first of two graduate writing programs. Today, Maud-- dear God, why-- is dead. And I, by grace, am a writer-professor hurtling toward middle age.
25岁时，阿莫德是一个有充分理由相信自己未来道路还很长的跑者。25岁时，我考入了两个研究生写作项目中的第一个。今天，阿莫德——天哪，为什么——死了。而我，因恩典，成了一名奔向中年的作家教授。
At 1:04 PM on February 23, a security camera shows 25-year-old Ahmaud Arbery wandering up a sunny patch of narrow road and stopping on the lawn of a sand-colored, under-construction bungalow addressed 220 Satilla Drive. Maybe he wondered what the skeleton of beams, and sheetrock, and piping, and wire would look like when it was finished. Maybe he imagined a family who could afford to live in a place so close to the water.
2月23日下午1点04分，监控摄像头显示25岁的阿莫德·阿伯里在狭窄的阳光小路上漫步，停在萨蒂拉大道220号一栋沙色、在建的平房草坪上。也许他想知道那些梁柱、石膏板、管道和电线的框架建成后会是什么样子。也许他想象着一个能负担得起住在离水这么近的地方的家庭。
What we know for sure is that while inside, Maud touched none of the construction materials laying about. We also know that Maud wasn't the first person whose curiosity urged them into the site. Security cameras recorded a white couple one evening, a pair of white boys one day, and on four occasions, what appears to be the same person-- a slim, young Black man with wild natural hair and tattoos on his shoulders and arms. The homeowner will confirm that nothing was ever stolen or damaged during any of the visits.
我们确实知道的是，阿莫德在里面时，没有触碰任何散落的建筑材料。我们也知道阿莫德并不是第一个因为好奇而进入该场地的人。监控录像记录了一对白人夫妇一个晚上造访，一对白人男孩一天造访，以及四次看似同一个人——一个身材瘦削、留着狂野自然卷发，肩膀和手臂上有纹身的年轻黑人。房主将证实，在这些访问期间没有任何东西被偷或损坏。
At 1:07 PM, a neighbor spying on Maud called 911. There's a guy in the house right now, he told the dispatcher, and went on to describe Maud-- Black guy, white T-shirt. The dispatcher replied, I just need to know what he was doing wrong.
下午1点07分，一名监视阿莫德的邻居拨打了911。他告诉接线员，那栋房子里现在有个家伙，接着描述了阿莫德——黑人，白色T恤。接线员回答说，我只需要知道他做错了什么。
The caller watched Maud leave the site. He's running down the street, he said to the dispatcher. Maud jogged past the house located a few doors down of another neighbor, Gregory McMichael, an ex-cop that had once had his power to arrest stripped for failing to attend use-of-force training.
拨号者看着阿莫德离开现场。他告诉接线员，他正沿着街道跑。阿莫德慢跑经过了另一位邻居格雷戈里·麦克迈克尔的家，他曾是一名警察，因未能参加武力使用培训而被剥夺了逮捕权。
Gregory and his son, Travis McMichael, armed themselves, the son with a shotgun and the father with a .357, and hopped in a white Ford pickup truck. From his front yard, William "Roddie" Bryan saw his neighbors hounding Maud, jumped in his pickup, and joined the chase. Maud ran and doubled back to elude the McMichaels, maybe recalling all the times he'd juked a would-be tackler on the field, only to find himself facing down Bryan's pickup. The elder McMichael, Gregory, climbed into the bed of his son's truck, the one with the Confederate decal toolbox, armed with his .357.
格雷戈里和他的儿子特拉维斯·麦克迈克尔武装了自己，儿子拿着一把猎枪，父亲拿着一把点357手枪，跳进了一辆白色福特皮卡车。在自家院子里，威廉·“罗迪”·布莱恩看到邻居们在骚扰阿莫德，也跳进皮卡车加入了追逐。阿莫德奔跑并折回以避开麦克迈克尔父子，也许回想起了在赛场上多次晃过潜在阻截者的情景，却发现自己面对的是布莱恩的皮卡车。年长的麦克迈克尔，格雷戈里，爬进了儿子车厢后部，那辆有着邦联图案工具箱的车，手里拿着他的点357手枪。
He called 911. There's a Black male running down the street, Gregory told dispatch. Maud fled for minutes that must have felt like an eon.
他拨打了911。格雷戈里告诉调度中心，有个黑人正在街上跑。阿莫德逃亡了几分钟，那感觉一定像是一个纪元。
He found himself running toward a red-faced Travis McMichael who stood inside the door of his truck with his shotgun aimed. Maud zagged one way, then the other. Stop right there, damn it. Stop, shouted Gregory. Maud crossed in front of the hood of the truck where Travis headed him off and shot him in no more than a heartbeat.
他发现自己正朝着满脸通红的特拉维斯·麦克迈克尔跑去，对方站在车门内，手里端着猎枪。阿莫德左躲右闪。格雷戈里大喊，给老子站在那儿。停下。阿莫德从卡车车头前穿过，特拉维斯拦住了他，在心跳之间就开枪了。
The buckshot hit Maud in the chest, puncturing his right lung, ribs, and sternum. And yet somehow, he wrestled with Travis for the shotgun. And yet somehow, he managed to punch at him, fighting for what he must have sensed was the rest of his life. Travis fired his shotgun a second time, grazing Maud's hand. He fired a third point-blank shot, this time piercing Maud in his upper chest.
猎枪弹击中了阿莫德的胸部，穿透了他的右肺、肋骨和胸骨。然而不知怎的，他还是和特拉维斯抢夺猎枪。不知怎的，他设法挥拳击打他，为他一定预感到那是他生命的余生而战。特拉维斯第二次扣动了猎枪扳机，擦伤了阿莫德的手。他开了第三枪，近距离射击，这次贯穿了阿莫德的上胸部。
Shotgun in hand, Travis backed away, watched Maud collapse, and made not the slightest effort to tend him. Per the police report, his father, still clutching his revolver, ran to where Maud lay face down, blood leaking out of his wounds, rolled him on his back, and checked for weapons that he, nor no one else, found.
特拉维斯手持猎枪向后退，看着阿莫德倒下，完全没有试图救助他。据警察报告，他的父亲，依然攥着左轮手枪，跑到阿莫德趴着的地方，血正从伤口流出，把他翻过身来，检查他身上是否有武器，然而他和其他人一样，什么也没找到。
Glynn County police sirened onto Satilla Drive within seconds of the slaying. They cordoned the scene and investigated. They questioned the McMichaels, Gregory's hands bloody from rolling Maud onto his back. They also questioned William Bryan. And in an act that is, itself, another violence, they let all three go about their merry way as free men for almost three months.
格林县警方在凶杀案发生后几秒钟内拉响警笛赶到了萨蒂拉大道。他们封锁现场并进行了调查。他们讯问了麦克迈克尔父子，格雷戈里的手上还沾着把阿莫德翻过身时留下的血。他们也讯问了威廉·布莱恩。然后，以一种本身就是另一种暴力行为的方式，他们放走了这三个人，让他们逍遥法外将近三个月。
But before those squad cars reached the scene, Travis McMichael, per Brian's statement to investigators in May, called the 25-year-old whose life he'd just ceased for jogging a fucking N-word.
但在警车到达现场之前，据布莱恩五月份给调查人员的陈述，特拉维斯·麦克迈克尔管那个他刚刚因为慢跑而结束了生命的25岁年轻人叫了一声该死的N字词。
Ask yourself, who deserves to run? Who has the right? Ask yourself, who's a runner? What do they look like? Ask yourself, where do they live, and where do they run? And where can't they live, and where can't they run? Ask, what are the sanctions for asserting their right to live and run or, goddamn-you-me, to even exist in the world? Then question that, too.
问问你自己，谁有资格跑步？谁有权利跑步？问问你自己，谁是跑者？他们长什么样？问问你自己，他们住在哪里，在哪里跑步？他们不能住在哪里，不能在哪里跑步？问问，维护他们生存和跑步的权利，或者——该死的我——甚至仅仅在这个世界上存在的权利，会遭到什么样的制裁？然后也去质疑这些。
The NAACP once defined lynching as a death in which, one, there was evidence that a person was killed; two, the death was illegal; and three, a group of at least three actors participated in the killing. On February 23, 2020, a Black man out for a run was lynched in Glynn County, Georgia. He was 25 years young. His name was Ahmaud Marquez Arbery, called Quez by his beloveds, and Maud by most others.
全美有色人种协进会曾定义私刑为一种死亡事件，其中：一，有证据表明一个人被杀；二，死亡是非法的；三，至少三名行凶者参与了杀戮。2020年2月23日，一名去跑步的黑人在佐治亚州格林县遭到了私刑处决。他年仅25岁。他的名字叫阿莫德·马尔克斯·阿伯里，他的挚爱称他为奎兹，大多数其他人叫他阿莫德。
And what I want you to know about Maud is that he had a gift for impressions and a special knack for mimicking Martin Lawrence. And what I want you to know about Maud is that he was fond of sweets and requested his mother's fudge cake for the birthday parties he often shared with his big sister. That he signed the cards he bought for his mother, "Baby Boy." That he jammed his pinky hooping in high school, and instead of getting it treated like his sister Jasmine advised, he let it heal on its own, forever bent.
关于阿莫德，我想让你们知道的是，他有模仿的天赋，特别擅长模仿马丁·劳伦斯。关于阿莫德，我想让你们知道的是，他爱吃甜食，生日聚会时总是要求母亲为他做软糖蛋糕，他常与大姐姐一起过生日。他为母亲买的卡片上签着“宝贝儿子”。他高中打球时弄伤了小指，但他没有听从姐姐贾斯敏的建议去治疗，而是让它自然愈合，结果永远弯曲着。
What I want you to know about Maud is that the love of his short life, Shenice, told me he sometimes recorded their conversations so he could listen to her voice when they were apart. What you should know about Maud is that he adored his nephews, Marcus III and Micah Arbery, that when they were upset as babies, he'd take them for long walks in their stroller until they calmed.
关于阿莫德，我想让你们知道的是，他生命中短暂的爱人申妮丝告诉我，他有时会录下他们的谈话，这样在他们分开时就可以听她的声音。关于阿莫德，你们应该知道的是，他宠爱他的侄子们，马库斯三世和米卡·阿伯里，当他们还是婴儿哭闹时，他会推着婴儿车带他们走很远的路，直到他们平静下来。
What you should know about Maud is that when a college friend asked his big sister which parent she'd call first if ever in serious trouble, she said, neither, that she'd call him. What I want you to know about Maud is that he was an avid connoisseur of the McChicken sandwich with cheese. You should know that Maud dreamed of a career as an electrician and of owning a construction company.
关于阿莫德，你们应该知道的是，当大学朋友问他的大姐姐如果遇到严重麻烦会先给哪个家长打电话时，她说，谁也不打，她会打给他。我想让你们知道的是，阿莫德是一位热衷于麦香鸡加奶酪的鉴赏家。你们应该知道阿莫德梦想成为一名电工，并拥有自己的建筑公司。
You should know that he told his boys that he wanted them all to buy a huge plot of land, build houses on it, and live in a gated community with their families. You should know that Maud never flew on a plane, but wanderlusted for trips to Jamaica, Africa, Japan.
你们应该知道，他告诉他的哥们，他希望他们能一起买一大块地，盖上房子，和家人一起住在封闭式社区里。你们应该知道，阿莫德从未坐过飞机，但渴望去牙买加、非洲和日本旅行。
What you must know about Maud is that when Travis McMichael, Gregory McMichael, and William "Roddie" Bryan stalked and killed him less than three months shy of his 26th birthday, he left behind his mother, Wanda, his father, Marcus Sr., his brother, Buck, his sister, Jasmine, his maternal grandmother, Ella, his nephews, 6 uncles, 10 aunts, a host of cousins, all of whom are unimaginably, irrevocably, incontrovertibly poorer from his absence.
你们必须知道的是，当特拉维斯·麦克迈克尔、格雷戈里·麦克迈克尔和威廉·“罗迪”·布莱恩追踪并杀害他时，离他26岁生日还有不到三个月，他留下母亲万达、父亲老马库斯、哥哥巴克、姐姐贾斯敏、外祖母埃拉、侄子们、6位叔叔、10位阿姨和一大群堂表兄弟姐妹，他们所有人都因为他的离去而变得不可想象地、不可逆转地、无可争辩地贫困。
Ahmaud Marquez Arbery was more than a viral video. He was more than a hashtag or a name on a list of tragic victims. He was more than a headline, or an op-ed, or a news package, or the news cycle. He was more than a retweet or shared post. He, doubtless, was more than our likes, or emoji tears, or hearts, or praying hands. He was more than an RIP T-shirt or placard.
阿莫德·马尔克斯·阿伯里不仅仅是一个病毒式传播的视频。他不仅仅是一个标签或悲剧受害者名单上的一个名字。他不仅仅是一个头条新闻、一篇专栏文章、一条新闻报道或新闻周期。他不仅仅是一次转发或分享的帖子。他，无疑，不仅仅是我们的点赞、表情包眼泪、爱心或祈祷的手势。他不仅仅是一件纪念T恤或标语牌。
He, for damn sure, was more than the latest reason for your liberal white friends' ephemeral outrage. He was more than a rally or a march. He was more than a symbol, more than a movement, more than a cause. He was loved.
他，该死地，不仅仅是你那些自由派白人朋友短暂愤怒的最新理由。他不仅仅是一次集会或游行。他不仅仅是一个符号，不仅仅是一场运动，不仅仅是一个事业。他是被爱着的。
Mitchell S. Jackson. The full essay that he wrote about Ahmaud Arbery, you can read online. It was in Runner's World. He's a poet, a fiction writer. His latest book is a memoir. It is called Survival Math, Notes on an All-American Family.
米切尔·S·杰克逊。他关于阿莫德·阿伯里的全文散文，可以在网上阅读。刊登在《跑步者世界》上。他是一位诗人、小说家。他的最新著作是一部回忆录，名为《生存数学：关于一个全美家庭的笔记》。
The McMichaels and William Bryan have been indicted on nine charges each, including malice murder and four counts of felony murder. All three men have pleaded not guilty.
麦克迈克尔父子和威廉·布莱恩都被控九项罪名，包括蓄意谋杀和四项重罪谋杀。这三人都表示不认罪。
Act Four, Bachelorette in Arlington. Linah Mohammad turned 25 this July in maybe the last place that she expected to be-- back at her parents' house in Texas. She had fought hard to get out of that home. Her parents are Palestinian with traditional values.
第四幕，阿灵顿的单身女郎。琳娜·穆罕默德今年七月满25岁，身处她可能最没预料到的地方——回到了父母在得克萨斯州的家中。她曾努力奋斗离开那个家。她的父母是巴勒斯坦人，拥有传统的价值观。
And of the four kids in her family, Linah is the only one to move out before getting married. And without getting married, she moved away to pursue a career. Being independent is very important to her. But then COVID hit. Linah explains what happened.
在家里四个孩子中，琳娜是唯一一个在结婚前就搬出去的人。而且她在没有结婚的情况下搬走是为了追求事业。独立对她来说非常重要。但后来新冠疫情爆发了。琳娜解释了发生了什么。
After two months in lockdown alone, I thought I was doing OK. But when I did a story for my job at The Washington Post where I admitted to a former prisoner, who was kept in solitary confinement in Iran, that I was losing my mind, and did he have any advice on how I could cope, my boss gently suggested that maybe moving home to Texas, back in with my parents, was the way to go. It was a hard decision to make.
独自在封锁中待了两个月后，我以为自己过得还行。但当我为工作——华盛顿邮报——做一篇报道时，我向一位曾被关在伊朗单独监禁的前囚犯坦白说我快疯了，问他有什么应对建议时，我的老板温和地建议说，也许搬回得克萨斯州，回到父母家是个好办法。这是一个很难做的决定。
To my surprise, being home was actually fun. I forgot how much my parents act like a comedy duo. They make fun of each other. When my dad, who I call Baba, misplaces his tools, he'll start yelling and gesturing wildly. Mama will start mimicking him until he realizes how ridiculous he looks and laughs.
令我惊讶的是，回家实际上很有趣。我忘了父母演起双簧来像喜剧二人组一样。他们互相取笑。当我父亲——我叫他巴巴——乱放工具时，他会开始大喊大叫并疯狂比划。妈妈会开始模仿他，直到他意识到自己看起来有多荒谬，然后大笑起来。
I'm their only child who grew up in both Jordan and the US, so the one thing they're in alliance on is making fun of how American I am. This was the good side of being home. The bad side? I was immediately reminded of all the ways my parents felt responsible for directing my life.
我是他们唯一一个在约旦和美国长大的孩子，所以他们唯一达成联盟的一点就是取笑我有多么“美国化”。这是回家的好的一面。坏的一面呢？我立刻想起了父母觉得有责任指导我人生的所有方式。
Mama interrupted a work Zoom meeting to tell me to make my bed and "Walik mshan ALLAH, ratby hal mazbaleh!" which means, please, for the sake of God, clean this dumpster. We also get into screaming matches about how I don't pray enough, which is a funny thing to scream about. And always, we fight about the fact that I am not yet married. I'd be fixing my hijab in the kitchen, and she'd sneak up behind me. Linah, if you wear it high like that, your hairline will recede, and you'll end up alone. What? I'm only trying to help.
妈妈打断了我的工作视频会议，让我去铺床，还喊着“Walik mshan ALLAH, ratby hal mazbaleh!”，意思就是，拜托，看在上帝的份上，清理一下这个垃圾场。我们也常因为我不够虔诚祈祷而进行尖叫式的争吵，关于祈祷这件事尖叫本身就很滑稽。而且我们永远在为我还没结婚这件事吵架。我会在厨房里整理头巾，她会偷偷从背后跟过来。“琳娜，如果你戴得那么高，发际线会后移的，你最后会孤独一生的。”“什么？我只是想帮忙。”
In her eyes, I should have gotten married by at least 23. And now I was about to turn 25, which sent Mama into panic mode. 25. For many Arab women like me, turning 25 feels like the cutoff age for eligibility, especially if you come from a lower class family, which I do. I grew up hearing about that age and fearing it.
在她眼中，我至少应该在23岁时就结婚。而现在我快满25岁了，这让妈妈进入了恐慌模式。25岁。对于像我这样的阿拉伯女性来说，25岁感觉像是结婚资格的截止年龄，尤其是如果你像我一样来自底层的传统家庭。我从小听到这个岁数就会感到害怕。
At 25, you start getting called A'anis, which means spinster. Mama will say, do you think you're still young? Of course, I'm still young. To which she'll respond, "Elly kaddek Endhom O'rr wlad," which means, other girls your age have so many kids, it's uncountable.
25岁时，你开始被称为“ spinster”（老处女）。妈妈会说，“你觉得你还年轻吗？”当然，我还年轻。而她会回答，“Elly kaddek Endhom O'rr wlad”，意思就是，和你同龄的其他女孩都已经生了数不清的孩子了。
The thing is, they act like I don't want to get married, but I do. I want to find someone. In fact, I always imagined I'd be married by now. I just didn't want to do it the way my parents expected-- a traditional arranged marriage.
问题是，他们表现得好像我不想结婚一样，但我确实想。我想找到某个人。事实上，我一直以为我现在应该已经结婚了。我只是不想以父母期待的方式——传统的包办婚姻。
I thought it would happen naturally. It hasn't. I even almost got married when I was 19, but that was a disaster. Since then, I've tried my way. I've dated in college. I've also used Tinder, Bumble, Minder, which is the Muslim Tinder, and Muzmatch, an unfortunately-named Muslim dating app. It has not worked.
我以为这会自然发生。但并没有。19岁时我甚至差点结婚，但那简直是一场灾难。从那以后，我尝试了自己的方式。我在大学里约会过。我也用过Tinder、Bumble、Minder（那是穆斯林版的Tinder），还有Muzmatch，一个名字不幸的穆斯林约会软件。都没用。
One guy really understood the Arab side of me, but couldn't speak English. Another was so funny, but looked down on women who swore. The guy I was engaged to was charming, but so controlling that he was adamantly opposed to me interviewing men, which is hard when you're a journalist. After all that, I was still alone.
有一个男士确实理解我的阿拉伯一面，但不会说英语。另一个非常风趣，但瞧不起说脏话的女性。我和我订过婚的那个人很有魅力，但控制欲极强，他坚决反对我采访男性，这在你是记者时非常困难。经过这一切，我依然是一个人。
So a few weeks before my 25th birthday, when Mama got a call, seemingly out of the blue, about an eligible boy, I did something I'd never done before. I said, OK, I'll meet him, partly to please her and get her off my back and partly because I realized, if I was so bad at choosing for myself, who's to say my parents couldn't do better? So I agreed to a traditional setup. Our mothers arranged for our first date, with both sets of parents, in my family's living room.
所以在25岁生日前几周，当妈妈接到一个看似没头没脑的、关于一个合适男孩的电话时，我做了一件从未做过的事。我说，好吧，我去见见他，一部分是为了取悦她，让她别再念叨我，另一部分是因为我意识到，如果我自己在挑选对象方面这么糟糕，谁说父母不能做得更好呢？所以我同意了一个传统的安排。我们的母亲安排了我们的第一次约会，在双方家长的陪同下，在我家客厅里进行。
Mama helped me get ready. As I was getting dressed, she reminded me of all the things I couldn't do. Don't you dare tell him that you have PCOS. That's Polycystic Ovarian Syndrome. It could make him worried you can't have kids. Don't bring up that you're taking antidepressants, have anxiety, or that you go to therapy, or that you were married-- it was technically just an engagement-- or that you've ever dated before. If he asks about any of this, change the subject.
妈妈帮我做准备。我穿衣服时，她提醒我所有不能做的事。“别敢告诉他你有多囊卵巢综合征（PCOS）。他会担心你不能生孩子。别提起你在吃抗抑郁药、有焦虑症、正在接受心理咨询，或者你曾经结过婚——严格来说只是订过婚——或者你以前约会过。如果他问起这些，就换话题。”
My date arrived. He was actually kind of cute in person, but it was awkward. Our parents were on a date with us. Though it became a rare glimpse into what my parents are like on dates. Mama, it turns out, is an oversharer, and Baba is super chill.
我的约会对象到了。他本人其实挺可爱的，但很尴尬。我们的父母在和我们一起约会。尽管这让我难得一见父母在约会时的样子。结果证明，妈妈是一个过度分享者，而巴巴超级随和。
On these living-room dates, I shouldn't be the one asking the questions, because it's considered the man's job to initiate all conversation. But the guy isn't saying anything, so Baba jumped in, acting like my stand-in. He knows what I'm looking for in a guy, so all his questions were secretly related to my dealbreakers, like I want to be with someone who speaks Arabic. Baba started grilling him. How good is your Arabic? Can you read and write? His mom answered for him. Of course, he can.
在这些客厅约会上，我不应该去问问题，因为发起所有对话被认为是男人的工作。但那家伙什么也不说，所以巴巴插了进来，充当了我的替身。他知道我在找什么样的男人，所以他问的所有问题都与我的底线有关，比如我想和会说阿拉伯语的人在一起。巴巴开始对他盘根究底。“你的阿拉伯语有多好？会读会写吗？”他的母亲替他回答了。“当然会。”
Suddenly, the two parents were battling it out. Baba said, can you recite Quran? His mother jumped in. Yes, and his voice is so beautiful. The guy interrupted her. Actually, I can't. I burst out laughing.
突然间，双方家长吵了起来。巴巴说，“你会背诵古兰经吗？”他的母亲插嘴说，“会，而且他的声音非常优美。”那家伙打断了她。“事实上，我不会。”我笑得前仰后合。
I was on the fence. This man wouldn't even make eye contact with me. OK, so he's a shy guy. That means I'd have to drastically tone myself down. But then when he told Baba that, for his job, he can live and work anywhere, I got excited. Other guys had always expected me to give up my career and follow theirs. With this guy, I could keep my job and he could tag along. So what if we have nothing else in common?
我当时还在犹豫。这个男人甚至不跟我进行眼神接触。好吧，他是个害羞的家伙。这意味着我必须大幅度收敛自己的个性。但当他告诉巴巴，为了工作，他可以去任何地方生活和工作时，我兴奋了。其他的男人总是期望我放弃自己的事业去追随他们。和他在一起，我可以保住我的工作，他可以跟着我。那如果我们之间没有其他共同点又怎么样呢？
But then his mom started talking to me. I was telling her about my life in DC, blah, blah, blah, when she cut me off and said, yeah, I saw that in the ad. My mind just completely stopped. The ad?
但后来他的妈妈开始跟我聊天。我正跟她讲我在华盛顿的生活，哒啦哒啦什么的，她打断我说，“是的，我在广告里看到了。”我的思维彻底停滞了。“广告？”
I tried not to show her that I was clearly surprised, but in my head I was like, what the fuck is this woman talking about? What ad? I thought someone just happened to suggest to our mothers that we meet. But there was an ad? Mama, who clearly heard this, too, acted like she didn't. They changed the subject, but by the time we got to coffee, it was all I could think about.
我尽量不让她看出我的惊讶，但在心里我心想，这女人到底在说什么鬼话？什么广告？我以为是有人碰巧建议我们的母亲让我们见面的。但居然有个广告？妈妈，明显也听到了这一点，表现得像没听到一样。他们换了话题，但当我们喝咖啡时，我脑子里全是这事儿。
As soon as they left, Mama explained it wasn't her who put the ad out. It was a friend. But Mama left it up and kept it from me because she thought I'd hate it. I found the ad. I hate it.
他们一离开，妈妈就解释说放广告的不是她。是一个朋友。但妈妈把它留着并瞒着我，因为她认为我会讨厌它。我找到了那个广告。我讨厌它。
It starts with a line of pink emoji flowers-- an emoji I would never use, by the way. Then it reads, "25-year-old Palestinian. Born in Jordan, living in the US since 2012. Studied here. Beautiful, fair skin, blue eyes, veiled, beautiful. [ARABIC]. Blessed be the most gracious. There is no power except in Allah. She got married without sexual relations." That's referring to the engagement I broke off. "Her request is a highly educated young man. Contact me for the mother's number. Serious inquiries only."
它以一行粉色表情花开始——顺便说一下，我是绝对不会用这种表情的。然后它写着，“25岁巴勒斯坦女性。出生在约旦，2012年起住在美国。在这里受教育。美丽，肤色白皙，蓝眼睛，戴面纱，漂亮。[阿拉伯语]。赞美最仁慈的真主。除了真主，别无力量。她结婚时没有发生过性关系。”那是指我取消掉的那次订婚。“她的要求是一位受过高等教育的年轻人。联系我以获取母亲号码。仅限认真询问。”
Everything about it makes me cringe-- the fact it exists, the details it includes. My eyes aren't even blue. I don't like what they're selling-- my white skin? my lack of sexual relations? It doesn't include anything about me that I'm proud of or anything that actually mattered. The ad lays out so plainly the enormous gap between who I am and who I would need to be to match with someone in my community. The description of this Linah is so far from me, it kind of hurts to read.
这一切都让我感到极其尴尬——它居然存在、它包含的细节。我的眼睛甚至都不是蓝色的。我不喜欢他们推销的内容——我白皙的皮肤？我没有过性关系？它没有包含任何让我引以为傲的东西，也没有任何真正重要的事情。广告直白地揭示了我是谁，以及为了匹配社区里的某个人，我需要成为什么样的人，这两者之间巨大的鸿沟。这个对琳娜的描述离我太远了，读起来甚至有点伤人。
Looking at the ad, I realized I'm probably not going to find the partner I want, someone who's in between two worlds in the ways I am, in the ways I want to keep being. It feels so final. I am 25, and there is no one for me.
看着那个广告，我意识到我可能找不到我想要的伴侣，那种能像我一样在两个世界之间穿行的人，那种我想继续成为的人。这感觉如此终极。我25岁了，却没有适合我的人。
But for what it's worth, if I were to rewrite the ad, here's what it would say. Linah, 25, wants to become a foreign correspondent. Loves finding and making stories. She's religious in her own way. She fasts, but doesn't pray. She reads the Quran daily, but has smoked weed before. She has PCOS, goes to therapy, has been depressed, has had anxiety, has a mustache and a beard, will not relocate for a man's career, will not erase herself for your approval. Worries this means she will end up alone.
但不管怎样，如果我要重写这个广告，内容会是这样：琳娜，25岁，想成为驻外记者。热爱寻找和制作故事。她有自己的信仰。她斋戒，但不祈祷。她每天读古兰经，但抽过大麻。她有多囊卵巢综合征，看心理医生，患过抑郁症，有焦虑症，有小胡子和胡子，不会为了男人的事业搬迁，不会为了你的认可而抹杀自我。担心这意味着她会孤独终生。
Linah Mohammad. She's a producer of the daily Washington Post podcast Post Reports. You can find her-- yes, right now-- on Bumble.
琳娜·穆罕默德。她是华盛顿邮报每日播客《邮报报道》的制作人。你可以在——是的，现在——Bumble上找到她。
This song that you're hearing right now, by 25-year-old Robbie Groat, was written for our program today, performed by the Philadelphia band The Districts with Katherine Lample.
现在正在播放的这首歌，由25岁的罗比·格罗特创作，为我们今天的节目而作，由费城乐队“区域”乐队与凯瑟琳·兰普尔共同演绎。
Our program was produced today by Sean Cole and Diane Wu. The people who put together today's show includes Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Aviva de Kornfeld, Noor Gill, Damien Graef, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ben Phelan, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney.
我们今天的节目由肖恩·科尔和戴安·吴制作。参与制作今天节目的人员包括比姆·阿德温米、埃尔娜·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、达纳·奇维斯、阿维瓦·德·科恩菲尔德、努尔·吉尔、达米安·格拉夫、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、莉娜·米西齐斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、本·费伦、纳迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉和马特·蒂尔尼。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks to Lisa Pollak, Eli Hager, Chen Ying, Jing Wang, Zeyi Yang, Oliver Whang, Penina Beede, Julian Brizzi, Jeremy Willis, Gina Grotelueschen, Joe Richman, Tony Householder, Jasmine and Becca Canziani, Alex Might, Rasha Zamamiri, Alex Lee, Katrina Montanez, and DaLyah Jones.
我们的主编是萨拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼。高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。特别感谢丽莎·波拉克、伊莱·黑格尔、陈莹、王婧、杨泽毅、奥利弗·黄、佩妮娜·比德、朱利安·布里齐、杰里米·威利斯、吉娜·格罗特卢申、乔·里奇曼、托尼·豪斯霍尔德、贾斯敏和贝卡·坎齐亚尼、亚历克斯·麦特、拉沙·扎马米里、亚历克斯·李、卡特里娜·蒙塔内兹和达利亚·琼斯。
Quick reminder about the web page that we have set up with favorite episodes from our 25 years on the air. There are little blurbs from me explaining what is so special about each of the shows. The website address, so easy to remember, you could probably say it along with me right now, right? thisamericanlife.org/25years. Those are the numbers 2 and 5 in there.
简单提醒一下我们设置的那个包含25年来最喜爱剧集的网页。那里有我简短的描述，解释了每一期节目为何如此特别。网站地址，如此容易记住，你现在可能就能跟我一起说出来，对吧？thisamericanlife.org/25years。里面是数字2和5。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, when he was 25, he was at Woodstock. But all the smoke in the air from all that weed-- Torey was not used to that at all. He kept falling asleep. And while the bands played, he'd wake up now and then to say--
《此美国生活》由公共广播交流中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，当他25岁时，他在伍德斯托克音乐节。但空气中弥漫着大麻烟雾——托里完全不习惯那个。他不停地睡着。当乐队演奏时，他会时不时醒来喊——
Can y'all be quiet a little bit?
你们能不能安静一点？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more true to-life-adventure stories. Hit it, maestro.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多真实生活的冒险故事回来。开始吧，指挥。